this is a production of Cornell
University
okay good yeah so just I mentioned I am
a third-year PhD student and the Larry
smart lab up at Cornell Agrotech and my
research really focuses on looking at
the mechanisms and pathways of sex
determination in the dioecious bioenergy
crops in exposure area a little bit of
background
Salix the genus Salix conveys over 300
species almost all of these are
dioecious and shrub you belong to the
section Beatrix and these are short
rotation compost bioenergy crops so
they're grown in high density plantings
such as this and they can be compost
every two to four years and then the
chips are burned to generate heat which
must be used to produce electricity so
my research really focuses on the
specifics purpurea as a model system for
the troubles so here you can see the the
female catkins or flowers and the male
catkins or flowers and cilix is also a
close relative of the genus Pacus the
poplars which are another important
biomass in a per crop so first um when
you talk a little bit more about the
hetero comedic systems in angiosperms so
only about 5% of angiosperms are
dioecious and on these kinking into
others GW or XY systems so the ZW system
is the female Heather comedic system and
this is where the females are ZW and the
males are ZZ so this is you probably
most familiar with this as a system
that's present in birds kiwifruit are an
example of a crop that actually have a
ZW system and then this is in contrast
to the XY system where the males are the
header be xx that are XY and the females
are xx this is the system that's present
in mammals and clean humans and some
crops such as papaya and asparagus so
but what's really interesting about
Salix as well as popular as a both these
general have both XY and Z W systems in
the same genus and then insects for
Korea in particular the STR the
secretary nation region is on a portion
of chromosome 15 that contains about
foreigner genes so here is a phylogeny
that was generated by some of our
collaborators and this is of the whole
static AC family so then Salix and the
sister
populist poplars and what's unique about
the select HD family a lot of many
unique things is that they have
homomorphic sex chromosomes so that
means on most of the sequence across
these chromosomes is conserved and so
you can't really distinguish sex
chromosomes by karyotyping or flow
cytometry like you wouldn't say a lot of
animal species and so the sex
termination regions are not in combining
portions of autosomes essentially so
instead xperia it has a ZW system that's
present on chromosome 15 and this takes
up about 6.8 mega bases which as I
mentioned earlier has a before inner
genes and that's about 40% of chromosome
15 so the other 60% of that chromosome
is essentially not as though so this
presents a pretty big challenge when
trying to determine master regulators of
sex and so most of the other struggles
like cynic spurious seem to have a
chromosome 15 ZW system but as it gets
some more basal Salix such as zigzag
youa while they saw the chromosome 15
STR it's actually XY system and then in
the most basal of the Salix such
anaesthetics [ __ ] it's actually
chromosome 7 XY system and then we see
in the poplars chromosome 19 XY
chromosome 19 CW and chromosome 14 XY
systems as well and so this is really
interesting and indicates that despite
that you should being conserved across
the family the sex determination region
has both shifted chromosomes and change
header communiques systems multiple
times throughout the evolution of this
family and really presents Casey and the
genus Salix in particular as an
excellent resource to study sex
determination in angiosperms so for my
research we made use of RNA seek data
collected from 90 male and 90 female
catkins from an f2 family with the help
of a JDI and so this F 2 F Emily was
generated by crossing our reference male
individual and our reference female
individuals for which you have fully
sequenced genomes and then doing simply
mating from the 2 from 2 of the f1
individuals and then getting the f2
family and this is kind of a summary of
the background of pipeline I ran through
and I won't go into too much detail on
this but if you have more questions be
happy to answer them but basically I
used ec2 to do differential
expression WGC engine network analysis a
pathway analysis in the soundscape that
Peugeot eqtl mapping using matrix eqtl
and we also had some smaller nice deep
data that we were able to analyze and
this may apply here
the x-axis is the overall expression of
the genes and the y-axis is the log
twofold change in expression so positive
values are more male differentially
expressed and negative values are more
female differentially expressed so right
away you can see that there are
thousands of genes that are
differentially expressed these are
looking across the genome and so it 6mm
is always widespread genomically but my
research really wants to get a what are
the bastard regulator genes in the sex
determination region so existing models
of sex determination positive there's
likely one or two genes that control sex
determination and then also I'm
interested in what are the intermediate
genes between those one or two sex
determination genes and these sizes of
genes across a gene of their sexually
dimorphic so I used some of these
approaches to to start to tease that
apart and get at those so using these
different methods identified a series of
candidate genes located in the STR
scenario down from about 400 genes to
about eight genes and so these are genes
that are unique the first of all they're
unique to the wstr so they're present on
chromosome 15 W and in females but
absent for 15 Z and thus absent for
males in the network analysis I did they
had module membership to highly female
correlated modules and they also had
extreme and significant differential
expression and lastly genes I had a
functional annotation that is consistent
with something that might be involved in
sex dimorphism so first I mentioned
these ere are 17 homologues so these are
in around Austin where there a negative
regulator of cytokine II and there's
four copies here in the STAAR
and these are our strongest candidates
because they're also present in the
poplar s tier on chromosome 19 and
starter kinase signaling has been
implicated in the sex determination
pathways in both dioecious and Manisha's
crops so qem persimmon that are
dioecious crops and then also
cytokine assigments involved
female flower development in the
cucurbits and so this come here is the
the male of female aren't you full
change to negative eyes are more female
different she expressed so all these
candidate genes are highly female
different she expressed which makes
sense because they're in the their
present only in females we also had
expression data though from an unrelated
Manisha slide so a line that has both
male and female flowers on the same
catkin and so this shows the monitors to
female and then the money is to male
differential expression so for these
they are 17 genes should I have the
expression female they're also a little
to no expression in the Manisha's line
relative to choose a female and about
the same in male between male Mauritius
which is nothing so this indicates that
these might be males suppressor genes
there's also a tan Argonaut for
homologue and a double shredder on a
binding one protein and so these are
interesting because they're the terms so
one controls DNA methylation Walker goes
mrna silencing and these are both
enriched go terms in our bulk RNA seek
data set so these are also strong
candidates and they like the arrow 17
also show a very low expression in the
money shoots in males which indicates
that they are lie female suppressors
there's also this kind of uh nana tating
zinc finger transcription factor that is
also maybe a male suppressor and there's
one Jeana we think might be a female
inducer so gene that actually promotes
female traits this is a gate of 15
transcription factor this is involved in
floral and meristem development and it
shows very high expression in females
relative to males
no significant nervous-looking the
Manisha's and the females and very low
expression in the male's relative to
body Timon anxious and any case that it
might therefore be a female inducer so
these are some of the Kennedys we
identified I also did eqtl analysis so
EQ analysis looks at the expression of
genes and tries to correlate those two
polymorphisms across the genome
so do this in detail analysis we
identified 54 genes that had significant
associations with the STR that were
involved in full development and
secondary metabolism and these are the
two primary sex dimorphic phenotypes
that we can observe in catkin tissue so
among these were multiple mads box and
other floral development genes as well
as numerous phenol pro bono to interpret
pathway genes which are involved in
secondary metabolism we also identified
85 transcription factors that were
associated with the sex determination
region among these transcription factors
involved in secondary metabolism full
development and gibberellins england as
well and so these are candidate genes
for being intermediates between the sex
determination region and the thousands
of genes downstream they're
differentially expressed so all these
were to turn bonnet automatically but we
really need to validate these using
functional data this is kind of the next
step that i hope to accomplish in the
next several years we want to do dap
seek and chip seek to really validate
the binding set some of those
transcription factors we want to do
bisulfite sequencing to look at
genome-wide methylation that might
implicate that Argonaut for in being
involved validating these candid genes
to functional knockouts and over
expression in all those such as poplar
this we unfortunately can't do this in
Willow because it hasn't been
successfully transformed and we'd also
like to do approaching protein
interaction analyses on some of the
other non transcription factor candidate
genes in the STR to see if they're
actually involved in their canonical
pathways and what that might be
first thanks determination and with that
I would like to thank all the current
and former members of valeri smart lab
as well as our collaborators across the
US and China at various universities and
then the NSF grant that has supported
this research and with that I'll open it
up to questions there's one question
there yeah the question is how come
readers use the information about the
location of sex determination genes in
their breeding program yes that's an
excellent question so for one you know
to to breed willow you need a male and a
female so that alone to be able to
select everybody talked about that but
one thing I am working on is developing
markers to actually select for male and
female from seed claims
another really big use is that a lot of
the secondary metabolites as well as
some actually biomass traits are
correlated with certain sexes and so if
you're reading for for bioenergy or
biomass knowing what sex the plant is
can be very useful so you can select for
for the first sex which is really easy
to phenotype and then you can get
correlated biomass traits along with
that
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu